[Musik]
im sachsen-anhaltinischen minsdorf hat
die Deutsche Bahn den Bahnhof komplett
neu gebaut zwei ewig lange Bahnsteige
neue Lampen Leitsysteme für
Sehbehinderte und diesen Aufzugschacht
leider ohne Aufzug zu den Zügen geht es
nur über diese steile Treppe mit ihren
42 Stufen im Volksmund Himmelsleiter
genannt für viele Bahnkunden ein
unüberwindbares Hindernis würde auf
reich ist bin ich da drauf sauer ich
kann es ja nicht nutzen gar nichts weil
ich ja gerade auch aus Altenpflege
kommen und generell auch Mutter bin mit
kleinen Kind also ich finde es total
Schwachsinn für mich ist diese Sache
eine Fehlplanung seit 1996 baut die
Deutsche Bahn den Knotenpunkt
Dessau-Roßlau komplett um Gesamtkosten
rund 450 Millionen Euro mittendrin liegt
der Haltepunkt meinsdorf der wird
komplett erneuert samt Unterführung im
August kurz vor der Wiedereröffnung und
dann die Nachricht der neue
Aufzugschacht ist fertig ein Aufzug wird
aber nicht eingebaut der
Ortsbürgermeister fühlt sich getäuscht
von der Bahn
jahrelang vier Jahre lang hat man uns
hier im Glauben gehalten dass hier auch
in Fahrstuhl herkommt auf allen
Informationsveranstaltungen das waren
drei Bürgerinformationen und auf allen
Plänen waren bis vor der Eröffnung bis
zum Schluss war ich ein Fahrstuhlschacht
mit Fahrstuhl vorgesehen die Deutsche
Bahn teilt uns schriftlich mit dann den
Bahnhalt sei einfach zu wenig los
deshalb bleibt der Aufzugschacht leer
wir sind uns bewusst dass dies für
Rollstuhlfahrer und andere
mobilitätseingeschränkte Reisende
unbefriedigend ist bitten aber um
Verständnis dass es für den
barrierefreien Ausbau von Bahnhöfen
angesichts der Vielzahl von Bauprojekten
und der begrenzten Mittel Grenzen gibt
die Menschen fehlt aber nicht nur der
Aufzug der ganze Haltepunkt ist kaum
zugänglich keine Parkplätze für Pendler
auch keine Abstellflächen für Fahrräder
tja und der Bus hält auch nicht am
Bahnhof dann muss ich mir sagen lassen
von den Bahnen Angestellten
hier steigen nicht genug ein und aus
dann hätten sie sich doch das alles
sparen können mal gewährt sie hoch und
die jetzt hier mit Rollstühlen haben ja
keine Chance da muss was passieren sonst
ist Blödsinn warum haben sie auch dann
eine Fahrstuhlschacht gebaut übrigens
früher war der Weg zu den Bahnsteigen
wenigstens überdacht bei Eis und Schnee
kann die steile Treppe jetzt auch noch
zur gefährlichen Rutschbahn werden